this week our new series in short supply
is looking at how supply chain
bottlenecks could ruin americans holiday
plans thanksgiving of course is a time
when many families and friends gather to
eat a big meal complete with turkey with
stuffing pumpkin pie even but grocery
stores are already struggling to fill
empty shelves and people can expect to
pay record high prices for their holiday
food meg oliver shows us why you may
want to start hitting the grocery store
aisles today
thanksgiving is a few weeks away but
with so many supply chain issues i'm
here early to make sure i get all the
fixins here's the good news the usda
says there isn't actually a turkey
shortage this year but that doesn't mean
you're not going to be paying more the
birds are going to cost you an extra 10
to 15 percent if you're having a smaller
thanksgiving buy your turkey early the
smaller ones are expected to go first as
americans keep their gatherings intimate
and by the way if you're thinking of
having chicken as an alternative that
could be a problem too all poultry
prices are rising because of factors
like climate change making the grain
they eat harder to get so more expensive
and that cost is getting passed on to us
no thanksgiving would be complete
without pumpkin and that could be
another issue most of our canned and
pureed pumpkins come from illinois which
was hit hard by a fungus this year
aluminum shortages mean this and any
other canned goods are in shorter supply
that's because aluminum suppliers can't
get their hands on enough magnesium
which is produced in china and an
important part of the aluminum making
process farms are having a tough time
all around because of wood shortages
needed for shipping and labor shortages
especially migrant farm workers who
weren't allowed in the country during
the pandemic
if all of this is stressing you out and
you need a drink i hate to tell you this
but liquor may be harder to come by a
lot of booze comes from overseas and
companies are having a tough time
sourcing the bottles and they take time
to make
the overall message from the usda is
don't worry too much if everyone gets
only what they need there should be
enough to go around
oh boy we are joined now by cbs news
business analyst financial guru joe
schlesinger jill how are you i'm well uh
we saw meg oliver put two bottles of
booze into her cart there these prices
are it's serious business i mean people
are upset uh the bills are going up how
long can we expect these prices to
continue um this is well into next year
and when you talk to economists they say
there's a lot of factors behind this but
things should start to ease up maybe as
early as the end of the first quarter
probably not till the middle of next
year so we're talking you know a good
six to nine months before we see a lot
of price pressure ease and what's the
why here is there two or three reasons
good question there are so many reasons
let's go to the demand side so by the
way if you had to take econ 101 and you
slept during it now we're going to tell
you the man's side okay what happened we
have been out of the economy essentially
for almost 20 months and there was a lot
of pent-up demand for what we wanted we
used to actually spend a lot of money on
services during the pandemic we switched
to goods stuff right you're in your
house you're buying stuff and that
demand is surging and continues to surge
part of the reason is that we've got
excess savings more than two trillion
dollars americans saved beyond what they
would have pre-pandemic so there's money
that's available and you really want to
spend so that's the demand side demand
and then more to spend of course so what
happens if the prices remain high what
what effect would that have well i don't
know
let's get to the other side of this so
demand and then there's supply and then
the supply part is actually really
important we have had supply chain
problems and issues probably for about
10 or 20 years part of the problem is
that we've come to rely on places like
china and korea and even germany and as
the pandemic unfurled what we saw was
these some these areas would shut down
one after another after another so there
were huge production delays there were
warehouses that had to make big
decisions there were shipping companies
that had to change their routes there
were container companies for these ships
that moved stuff in the wrong direction
and on top of that i think that when you
think about how the virus unfolded the
opening was really kind of herky-jerky
meaning and opened in one place not in
the other ships are in the wrong place
containers are in the wrong place and
there's real bottlenecks
could this be
good in the long run for american
workers because the the need to fill
these jobs may mean higher wages better
benefits well i mean the supply shortage
and we've talked about this so much on
the program and that is that we have had
people out of the labor force maybe they
were sick themselves family members were
sick children were a home people were
out of the labor force because of child
care issues and when we look at where we
are now these shortages are only
exacerbating so yes higher wages are
part of the process to lure people back
in but remember those higher wages can
feed into the inflation problem right
because we're getting paid more now we
can pay more for the goods and services
i want to go back to nate's question
though if the prices remain high what
happens well i think this is an
important part of the the puzzle the
federal reserve met last week and the
chair jerome powell has consistently
said this is transitory or a temporary
problem well it may not be and if
inflation lingers more than expected
this can slow down economic growth so we
have seen growth in the first half of
the year at about six and a half percent
it's a huge number after we saw the
economy contract last year right now in
the third quarter the first reading was
two percent part of that had to do with
supply issues and inflation we're
expecting things to pick up but if
people don't have the money to spend on
higher priced goods and services guess
what the economy is going to slow down
all right best advice for the consumers
right now is buy that turkey today if
you can no the booze not the turkey well
you can freeze it you know all right use
the freezer in the garage all right all
right thank you very much and tomorrow
on our series in short supply we're
gonna be looking at holiday shopping
we'll find out how the supply chain
gridlock will affect the price you pay
for this season's hottest gifts and why
you may have to hurry up and buy them
once again so that they will arrive in
time for the holidays and you can hear
more about this crisis on today's cbs
mornings podcast when we talk with nick
vias head of usc's global supply chain
institute they've got an institute now
he explains why the disruptions could
have been predicted and what can be done
to fix them